the Israeli Prime Minister remains
defiant as he addresses the country
following his indictment you have to be
blind not to see that something bad is
happening with the police and the
prosecutors tonight we're witnessing an
attempted coup with false allegations
and a tainted investigation that
investigation lasted years on Thursday
Israel's Attorney General announced his
decision to formally press charges when
the Attorney General decides to indict
an Acting Prime Minister for severe
charges of corruption is a difficult and
sad day for the Israeli public and for
me personally the case is against Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu are known as
case 1000 Netanyahu and his family are
suspected of receiving gifts from
business colleagues and close friends
case 2000 covers allegations that
Netanyahu attempted to influence the
publisher of a daily newspaper to gain
more positive coverage the recommended
charges in both cases fraud and breach
of trust and case 4000 allegations of
regulatory favors for Israel's largest
telecommunications company in exchange
for positive media coverage the charges
here fraud breach of trust and bribery
Netanyahu has rejected all the
accusations and says he will continue to
lead the country his immunity as Prime
Minister means he won't be legally
forced to resign but his political
future hangs by a thread he has failed
to form a government after two
consecutive elections and he now faces a
legal process that could drag on for
years joining us now here in the studio
is DW Mideast analyst Shani Roos honest
good morning fuchsia nice to see ya
Benjamin Netanyahu he's the longest
serving Prime Minister in Israel can he
managed to survive this
politically well I know better than to
say these is it last days Oh too many
commentators have fallen into that trap
in the last year's when things seem to
be getting dire and ire
it is however this time serious more
than ever and we have seen even before
the the indictment charges were brought
we saw yesterday morning already people
from his own party challenging him
calling for primaries calling for
elections for the leadership of the
Likud because he was not contested since
2014
so if we see his own base starting to
rise against him and we will see we've
seen also in the second elections as
erosion mostly of the right not of the
left for going for a third round of
elections we might see Netanyahu or the
coup the right block be the ones
suffering the most okay no we heard our
report dead that he could survive this
politically for a number of years is
that really possible
well what he's trying to do it was clear
yesterday in a speech he's starting his
campaign and his his line is quite clear
this is an illegal illegitimate an
attempt of the lefty elite to bring down
the right and me as a sitting Prime
Minister it can't work it can resonate
with his audience especially and we need
to remember his coalition he has a mini
coalition with some other parties in the
parliament who are supporting the bloc
the 55 bloc two of the leaders of the
parties connected to that block they're
themselves are facing charges so they
don't having a particular interest in
being kind to the police this kind line
of campaign serves them very well so so
Benjamin Netanyahu could remain
potentially in offices all day for at
least these three weeks well at least
three weeks unless we I mean if if we
see a major political earthshake it
should probably into next week otherwise
we will probably see him for the next
couple of months until the third term of
election is coming which would be
probably early March 3rd of March and he
can definitely stay in office until then
if into the spring all right now
opposition leader Bennigan's is saying
there's no way he could stay in office
now pointing out that any decisions of
state he makes could be for personal
reasons is that gonna play out in in in
the new election campaign you mentioned
of course I mean of course everybody is
you know getting geared for their new
campaign but this is the question
exactly the question does the Preem
court will have to will have to
determine it because there's no doubt
whatever comes now whatever political
scenario comes whatever happens in the
Knesset and the Parliament that is it's
gonna end up being decided by the
Supreme Court someone will appeal from
either side
and the Supreme Court will have to
decide this is the president's that all
they'll have to set can a sitting Prime
Minister also be one fighting actively
you know charges against him where does
this turmoil leave the country and I
have to ask who's running the country
well officially Netanyahu his government
they're still in office it's it's clear
there's the great stagnation we talked
about budget when you talk about the
need for social services everybody's
realizing this is not an ideal situation
the last round in Gaza last week have
shown us that things are very shaky this
is partially why the the hope and the
expectation of Netanyahu to step down is
is is you know it's something that is
unrealistic he is not he feels he uses
this instability as a proof of why he
needs to stay and keep you know his
whole tight over the government even
though it's not as tight as he wishes
and that could expand even his base as
you mentioned Shani was honest thanks so
much for coming in Shani